un acuerdo clave alcanzado entre dos
vecinos serve kosovo han logrado un
acuerdo que permite la libre circulación
de personas entre sus países
serbia ha accedido a suprimir el
documento de salida de entrada para los
titulares del dni de kosovo y con sólo
ha acordado no introducirlos para los
titulares de un documento de identidad
serbios los serbokosovares al igual que
el resto de ciudadanos podrán viajar
libremente entre kosovo y serbia
utilizando sus tarjetas de
identificación using the a haití
el acuerdo se alcanzó en bruselas tras
las conversaciones mantenidas esta
semana entre el primer ministro de
kosovo albin kurti y el presidente
serbio aleksandar vucic el jefe la
política exterior de la unión europea
josep borrell que presidió las reuniones
agradeció a ambos dirigentes por
encontrar una solución europea que
permita viajar y ayudar a aliviar la
creciente tensión en la región en las
últimas semanas se han producido
violentos enfrentamientos en kosovo cuyo
estatus de independencia en 2008 aún no
es reconocido por serbia una minoría de
serbios aún presente en el norte del
país reaccionó airadamente a la ya
despreciada ley que declaraba que los
documentos de identidad emitidos por los
serbios ya no eran válidos en el
territorio de kosovo pero una segunda
ley posiblemente más compleja sigue sin
resolverse una que exige que todos los
residentes cambien las matrículas de sus
coches por las kosovares a partir del 1
de septiembre mientras tanto las fuerzas
de paz de la otan han aumentado su
presencia en el norte de kosovo los
serbios locales se han enfrentado
esporádicamente con la policía y con los
residentes de origen albanés